a community in North Las Vegas has
rallied together to evict squatters
living in a foreclosed home today they
thanked police officers and City
officials by hosting a block party the
house is near Decatur and Deer Springs
Joshua baguero has the story
[Applause]
Kathy Hendricks is happy to see her get
a community in a festive mood the reason
a few months ago bad neighbors were
causing problems and she says their
house became a hotbed of crime it was
really bad and it was getting worse and
I would tell that police officers every
time we would call them I'm like I'm
really worried with some of the people
that are coming to this home and the
activity that's happening someone's
going to get hurt or killed neighbors
tell me their problem started in 2020
when squatters started occupying this
house they would leave garbage all over
the floor drug paraphernalia as well and
as you can see now the home is
inhabitable for us to retire I didn't
want to be living with crime around me
that was not my focus and I'm like no
Hendrix sought the help of others on our
streets Erica menasco who lives right
across from the problem house became her
partner in crime throughout all hours of
the night manasco would see Shady
characters the house was in foreclosure
it was it was it was borderline ready to
be condemned and they were taking
advantage of that situation and this is
not the neighborhood to do that
neighbors began showing up to city
meetings and contacting council members
enter councilman Scott black who
listened to their concerns and how the
meeting between residents and City staff
the city Prides itself on finding
solutions for neighborhood safety for
beautification and it was just an
awesome collaboration the house has been
sitting empty since last November near
Decatur and Deer Springs Joshua paguero
eight news now City officials say if you
have problems in your neighborhood make
sure to call 311 or code enforcement